here's another question when you were
in the throes of addiction you know
actively shooting up as much as you
possibly could yeah
like how did you not get like aids and
[ __ ] where were you like sharing needles
and should you just get super lucky
my
newest book that came out there's a
chapter called the aids needle that i
shot up with yeah and like
things got really bad i'm living in
these abandoned houses in east baltimore
and i remember i was doing my deal and
the needle uh jammed up right and it's
like the middle of the night and it's
so i'm
look on this floor and it's just
polluted with all these dirty needles
used needles and i literally
kind of process of elimination looked
for the one that was the least used like
this one doesn't have a's on it this one
does this one
this one probably out of all of them
might not like this is my best shot of
it no like don't you give yourself a
pretty good chance if you just flush it
through with water
bleach
blade okay but even water would help
right because what it is about
hypodermic needles that makes it so uh
dangerous for hiv is that in that hollow
needle in there it the the hiv virus is
not exposed to air like on a tattoo
needle it's a solid needle so
everything's exposed to air it's very
difficult to get aids from that
at that point in time my life i had no
idea of any of that knowledge that
wasn't my
reference you know it was just flush
through i'm just like sick let's let's
do it
right and um
and i i use the needle and
you're making it sound like it was one
night you're telling me you never should
know i i did but this is the one time
where like i thought like
i definitely just got it right like it
was one time that was really stuck out
above all the other times that i've
shared needles right and uh and i've
done it often at that point in time so
a few months later on the line i'm sick
and there's this place it's kind of like
a health clinic and they're paying you
uh 30 to get blood work done so they pay
you 30 to get the blood work done and
then they give you 10 or no i'm sorry
they give you 20 to come back and pick
the results up so
it's a medical study and they're testing
like different ways of uh they want the
drug addicts to come in a to get tested
so they know they'll do that with the
money and then the 20 on the back end to
pick it up to get the
the results so when you come in they're
also giving you clean needles clean
because they're it's kind of a
harm reduction deal right and and uh i
think there's a great many addicts that
just don't want to know if they have hiv
or not and so that's they give they're
really paying you 20 bucks to inform you
because should the addict know that they
have hiv then maybe they'll be a little
bit more responsible about spreading it
ignorance is no longer bliss right point
proven so i i get i go 30 bucks let him
take a test cool no no intentions ever
to go back and get the results because
i'm [ __ ] you're like dude i don't
need 20 bucks that bad no i'm living in
until one day i needed the 20 bucks that
bad right so i go back were you so
scared terrified and they they they give
me the 20 and the doctors and i said
look doctor please i beg you
just don't tell me if i have hiv you can
tell me anything else just give me it
all but that
and he says
well the good news is you don't have hiv
but the bad news is you have hepatitis c
and i [ __ ] high-fived him
he was like what the [ __ ]
oh god i remember when uh
like i had my family all like um giving
me a hard time about my lifestyle and my
addiction and i was like look i'm gonna
go to this [ __ ] uh executive health
program like uh and get the most
comprehensive checkout known to man
because dr drew told me about it wasn't
even covered by insurance because it was
just so like extra yeah i'm like i'm
gonna get tested every [ __ ] test you
can possibly if i come back healthy then
you guys get off my back and i was just
like dude of course i'm gonna come up
clean so i go i go up uh get all these
tests and then the doctor calls okay i
need to give you your results in person
oh that's like that's a horrible sign so
i go in there and i'm thinking [ __ ] man
like what what what is like what's wrong
with my water i'm scared for you right
now i go into the doctor's office and
i'm like doc
is it my wiener
you know
like i said like i'm thinking like i've
got some terrible std he goes no your
wiener's fine and i'm like whoa yeah
and uh he says oh no it's your heart he
says you've got a heart condition he's
you've got the heart of an 80 year old
man oh wow like i don't see you living
to the age of like 40 or something like
that and i was like who that high-five
yeah right
[ __ ] my heart my wiener's cool
i'll [ __ ] my way into heaven yeah and
then it turned out that uh that i would
like i had very like borderline
cardiomyopathy like
minor
so did you do it
i think my heart's good dude
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]